hey guys this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video i want
to make a quick update
on the cryptocurrencies and see what
we're having on the bitcoin the dutch
coin
and the ethereum let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys let's start with the
dodge coin because the dutch coin there
was a lot of hype around
this cryptocurrency and guys go check
the videos i did
one week and two weeks ago i was telling
you guys by the rumor
sell the news i was telling you guys one
week before elon musk was talking that
it would go higher and that we probably
gonna reach
0.8 that is here that we're gonna
correct
and that we're gonna do a final wave for
now i'm 100
right on this so what happened here guys
is that when elon musk
started to talk we actually saw the
dutch coin
it was here going lower so we didn't go
to open 8 we went to 0.75
so i was a bit off here but you know
generally speaking i was kind of very
accurate
so here what we're having right now we
finished the third wave so we are
correcting
we're doing an abc so this was rather
flat so here
we have a zigzag that makes sense all
right i'm not sure it's finished or not
let's see it can still go like this all
right
but correcting to open 35 seems very
fair
it's a level i gave you guys before
already i told you that
we might see it it's the maximum level
we had on the wave one
here so it makes sense that we correct
to
this level on the force wave in my
higher degree wave counting
and what i can tell you guys right now
and you're gonna see because
on the cryptocurrency i don't know why
things just happen exactly the way i say
it
you can check on gamestop and amc i'm
struggling a bit i still think i'm gonna
be correct in the medium term
but the short term is giving me some
hard time
on the cryptocurrencies guys it's like
very clean
and my scenarios all happen almost
so we reached this corrective level i
can tell you that we are going now to
120 130
all right so i'm talking about to move
up of
300 so if you want to take it take it
but i'm very convinced of this i'm not
gonna go
through here my counting again but we
are missing this
fifth wave i'm very convinced it's gonna
come
so i'm done for the dutch coin let's go
on the bitcoin so remember what i was
telling you guys this was my
very first scenario in the beginning
then i updated it
so how do we stand right now i'm still
in this
abc big corrective pattern this is a
so we're doing here this one two three
four five
all right let me arrange it a bit
so this is what is happening now this is
the a wave
b wave you know the a wave doing an abc
all right here we go so you don't need
that
so this is a b c and i expect
a strong rebound and then again to go
lower
so maybe during this rebound dutch coin
is going to go to 120 i don't know
but i told you guys that i was bearish i
told you i'm bearish
since 57 000 we are now at 50 000 i'm
still
bearish guys all right i still think
that
we didn't reach the corrective level i'm
talking about
42 000 guys we are going there you're
gonna see
and then we're gonna bounce back and
probably
go there again this is my scenario so
let's see if this is correct
but for now things worked out pretty
well and then we're gonna go to
the 130 000 area but later that's it for
me for the dutch coin
let's do the ethereum so ethereum guys i
was giving you a target
of 4200 we reached it
right now what is happening we are still
in this fifth wave
so let me do a bit of idiot wave
counting one two
three four five all right
so i think we finished the fifth wave i
was telling you we go go check my
previous video guys i told you we're
gonna go to four thousand two hundred
i used fib extensions and we went to
four thousand
four hundred all right so i was not that
far right now to be honest
we are still in the bullish development
but i expect some consolidation
this is only a first wave of the fifth
all right this is finished
so right now we're going to correct this
and do something like this all right
this is my scenario this could only as
well be like this
so let's see what is happening here it's
very interesting to see
how this is gonna correct i'm not sure
this is a one two three four five
basically i don't know if the fifth is
going to be extended or not but for now
we're having the fifth wave
that is complete we need to see if we're
having an extension or not
and we need to see what happens after
the correction if we move higher
it's probably an extension if we see
here some bearish signals like we
had on the bitcoin then i'm gonna let
you know i'm gonna tell you that
i'm turning bearish on the ethereum for
now i'm not
bearish for now i'm still bullish i'm
just expecting some correction
and maybe move higher so that's it for
me i hope you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show see you guys